hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the official attack on
Titan game now you may know that in the
past I've played a lot of these attack
on Titan games like this one and that
one and that one over there and then one
is like two games that I played I'm a
big fat liar I have no idea what I'm
talking about half the time and in all
honesty I'm just putting more work on my
poor editor so considering this is the
official game it actually has a story
mode that follows closely to the actual
anime or the original manga or whatever
you want to call it or whatever it is
the original story that you know about
attack on Titan that stuff happens in
this game I don't know about the future
of it but then down the road you might
know something more about it but I know
all this [ __ ] I want to get to the
game now ordinarily I wouldn't skip a
story like this but because it is attack
on Titan and it because it is the actual
game in relation to all that stuff I
want to just see myself zipping through
the city and fly seing the nape of neck
of all those Titan bastards I'm gonna
kill them dead I'm gonna kill them good
I gotta do a tutorial oh [ __ ] oh there
we go pressing the wrong button
oh good god the pelvic thrusting in this
game is immense
oh wow okay enough screaming like a mini
let's get into the game
yeah whoa okay I did it I got one I got
it good I don't know what I feel I did
but I did something ha ha
did I do it oops that didn't work at all
ah there we go
okay so you got a time the boost with
the slice II do and then oh this is
awesome I'm very excited about this one
oh hi hello who are you
you are logisticians I like the
logistician Oh be okay
oh it's so cool I want to get in combat
mode on you wants to slice you in the
nape of the neck to get your sweet
supplies what happened to her
holy [ __ ] she was a [ __ ] out of their
place the bleeds
then select the gas replaced the gas
good there we go slice at a nice okay
assemble my core come here Corps fellows
oh god strike as many limbs as possible
in the time allotted ready boom boom
stole your kill maybe you should have
been a little bit better about it
alright okay okay I'm getting it oh hell
yeah yeah
I love it I love it I love it I love it
it's exactly what I was hoping for out
of an actual attack on Titan game I know
I'm still doing the tutorial and
obviously you're not seeing the full
brunt of what this is we're sure
oh come on uh uh okay yeah I'm not doing
this one it's just cuz I'm trying to
hurry before everyone else gets it yeah
that's a bigger one
how about yeah that one oh come on
oh I press the wrong but no help if I
did that whoo ah ah just bouncing like a
rag doll up in the sink oh my face yeah
there we go
that's a slice 35 total holy [ __ ]
come on ski I'm still trying to remember
the button coordination for this it's a
little bit complicated but slowly
getting the hang of it like learning
piano ah hold my face there we go
I would I would love to see someone
who's like actually legitimately good at
this and not me I'm not good at it I
want to be very clear oh you guessed
that already oh you could guess that I'm
not good at it oh well thank you for
your expert opinion
oh there you want to get so if I boost
multiple times throughout the the
entirety of it I will get multiple
things but I need more Gaius no it's
mine
no one gets it except for me give me
your sweetness give it to all of me I
love the way the thing they moan into
the heavens right before they blast off
into the night sky hey they're all going
for that last one what it's mine oh no
I'm not gonna get there in time
nope it's dead okay alright it was me
wasn't it crap course it was course yeah
I doubt anyone could have done better
than Mikasa but maybe it was like maybe
if you did good enough but I doubt that
would have been possible yeah yeah you
suck Oh subjugation
I got an ass ranking hell yeah
alright now that we're done with the
actual I've learned the swoop I've
learned how to swap it woo call this one
the swoop it's it's an evolution of the
dab no it's not cool shut up I'm cool oh
man I'm gonna the thing is I'm only
gonna do one episode of this because I
die I'm only doing this because I want
to see what the actual legitimate
developers of this game are gonna do in
comparison to the ones that our fan made
games and see how the mechanics are
refined and so far I'm very impressed
this is super refined now I do not know
I I highly doubt I'm gonna do full
playthrough this I think this is gonna
be one episode for now
I'm gonna do one more mission with some
actual Titans to kill them dead but then
after that I think I might play this on
my own because it seems really fun it's
like what reminds me of a spider-man -
when you're zipping through the city
like what am I doing here oh my god am i
socializing oh my god can I flirt with
people is this also a visual novel oh my
god hey hey let me swaddle right up to
you Oh Joe God the way you turn your
head oh hey short stuff
shrimpy puss huh little man want a fight
oh yeah I didn't think so why is
everyone standing like this why is
everyone standing [ __ ] arm out why is
that happening
don't smile at me while you stand all
week everyone's doing it this cuz we
need to walk whoo we're preparing to
have these giant sword bags on our sides
the whole time it's like a cowboy with a
10-pound gun gesture on a gesture yeah
cool yeah what the [ __ ] am I supposed to
be doing here I can upgrade my [ __ ] with
bamboo oh yeah
I don't know what iron bamboo is but
okay
so apparently there's a crafting system
in this game and like an upgrade system
for your stuff that's interesting whoa
that is an interesting knife oh I like
it
oh I gotta play this on my own I gotta
uh yeah but that's not the point of this
video hey hey okay I'm ready
of course I'm ready give it to me see
these muscles you see this pose I've
never been more ready in my life yeah
really is it really is convenient that
they have no reproductive organs if
there were Titans walk around with
ten-foot dick slapping between their
thighs they'd be even more terrifying
than it was before okay so now we're
really getting into it oh holy [ __ ] well
alright then
okay mama gichan and in the knees you to
the nape of the neck now subjugated that
[ __ ] oh hell yeah nice nice oh hi oh not
again don't please we just built that
you're so angry
ah good yes another I was hoping oh what
a handsome devil that time is oh god
he's slappy whoo-hoo okay so he missed
me oh geez oh geez
leave used to restorative do I need to
get around and miss the thing he's
looking right at me
so I'm on
your slices arm up get behind him yes
okay
superior subjugation one failed attack
it wasn't it wasn't very good
beyond Oh big guy oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
the father-son combo here always slappy
oh god they're all so slappy how do I
focus Oh God
I've completely forgotten how to focus
oh there's your leg go yes this is going
much better than the actual anime what
you have if you have watched it it's
much less good and members include give
you items if you stand still next to him
ain't gonna stand still Titans
everywhere
hey okay he's got it yeah that went well
when it comes one at a time when they
all be swarming it's probably a bit more
of a problem that's still one more
I want to take down big man nice
whirligig style I like it dramatic but
not necessary
oh so angry
he's just gonna stand there Stockstill
walls of world if I don't know maybe
he'll see me Oscar is steaming in this
body of mine in this particular area
where I'm standing a part of active
volcano
laughter I'm tired you stand-in here
okay hit heaven oh you moved Oh God you
moved
oh it's protected by the most dangerous
of things yeah those automated mounted
camp oh I need to do that I'm gonna
blast your eyeball
ah
they found my one weakness my huge
enormous arms
Oh
how could I not see that coming
sure alright more killing this is what
I'm here for
well where am I go whoa where am I going
where am I going oh I almost made that
[Music]
hey buddy ignore the fact that I that
was all terrible let's go kill us some
titanos wait oh I didn't actually
recruit yeah I I didn't recruit him oh
[ __ ]
where did our where was armed Oh Armand
was over there I'm aware we gotta go get
him oh oh whoa what does that mean I
don't remember what green means I'm an
spence along side mission Oh side
mission who needs that when there's
times to kill
why didn't that work
oh okay well it was a team work I led
the team and therefore I get a lot of
the credit that's how this works right
okay can you ah there we go oh nice all
the blood please
all the blood all right I guess I could
go towards the smo signal oh good well a
waste not want not I suppose give me
your stuff they're very gross but okay
alright let's go we've got more people
to save what are you doing
that was a lot of yelling yeah remember
your training Boosh hey give me your
[ __ ] give me give me your [ __ ] what I
want your [ __ ] please then go straight
up into the oh I thought he was gonna
fly scrambler okay my people need me hey
look it's a giant rock I wonder how
that's gonna come in useful leave God
did I kill bees
oh geez it's so satisfying I love it oh
man I mean it's easy for me to say that
this is my favorite attack on Titan game
because obviously the other ones were
just fan main games but this is so well
made I mean obviously this probably took
a long time and it's kind of heavy
past the point where I would say that
attack on Titan was like at its peak
popularity not that it's really lost any
of it let's guy doing he's humping that
why is it why is he
why is he pumping that wall who knows
what Titans are all about they're so
weird oh I guess I'm going at this one
man oh I can't see me yeah I wish the
attack was like a trigger button that
would make a lot more sense than just
the Y button okay gotta gotta got it
gotta gotta got it
doing good doing good like assured
though Chong stop losing focus Oh God
okay I need more cow whoa whoa whoa I'm
actually concentrating and tried it too
good now I wanna I want to show you get
out I want it [ __ ] I want to show you
guys some what kind of good
not really but just some what kinda
I wasn't even close to you but it still
killed you that's just how good I am me
just shove new gas bladders in here
what's going on over there
virgins well he's probably gonna die
what am I gonna rush across town to help
that when I got a Titan right here yo
soy burger ovaries oh hello okay okay I
saw Russ across town now I'll get it on
the way
just cuz I'm completely on the other
side of the area wow I've recruited a
lot of these guys why are you all
following me trying to steal my glory
serious all right I'm comin up he's
gonna die who's this bird I can't get
over this wall I'm gonna make it I'm
gonna make it yeah I'm gonna make it oh
geez okay Megan they're not gonna make
it he's dead man whoa how did I do that
whoa disappeared I was I was right here
I was there it was the table
Hey okay good we
oh yes oh yes
nice oh hell yeah oh hell yeah oh hell
yeah that is so fun that is ludicrously
far okay so I think that's all I'm gonna
play for this video here it is super fun
I had a great time playing this I was
super happy the entire time I was
killing Titans now I've heard that later
on the game you do become a Titan
because that's part of the story and
then it kind of detracts from the
super-fun dance of just flying around
killing Titans but that's the story mode
there's actually an online mode I
believe where you can play with your
friends and attack on Titans together I
don't know why I keep wanting use those
verbs but either way it should be a lot
of fun so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video I'm so close I'm
gonna get cut big boy
[Music]